faire plein de questions confiance est
plus violent là encore alors jérôme
rodriguez vous j'ai vu que vous aviez
condamné le geste de francis lalanne
concernant les journalistes de
quotidiens je sais que vous les avez
condamné soleil est qu'est-ce que vous
est-ce que vous condamnez ce le geste de
cette personne on dit que je les fais
dès cet après midi via ma page facebook
mais il ne pas excuser de ne pas
cautionner ce geste de peut-être
l'expliqué tout simplement est-ce que ça
s'est également excusé est-ce que ça
s'explique à s'explique par le phénomène
de violence que nous subissions depuis
pas mal d'années et donc en france et
plus précisément depuis deux ans je peux
comprendre à un moment donné du moins
entendre l'exacerbation de certaines
personnes et qui en viennent à des
gestes violents
aujourd'hui j'entends monsieur guaino
sur la symbolique du président de la
république je l'entends moi j'ai plus
l'impression que c'est l'homme qui se
fait gifler et non pas le président de
la république qui n'en laissait et qu'en
est il aujourd'hui de l'agro un voyage
de fergus m'intéresse c'est inouï gens
ne faut pas dissocier l'homme de ces le
président de la république je suis
d'accord maintenant qu en est il du
symbole de la république de gens qui
manifestent dans une démocratie et qui
eux perdre leur oeil
je n'ai pas vu toute l'assemblée
nationale se lever donc quelle qu'elles
sont les symboles
moi même je suis apparemment un symbole
des mutilés des gilets jaunes qu'est ce
que ça veut dire symbole qu'est ce qu'on
en fait de ce symbole en tout cas
aujourd'hui je répète je ne cautionne
pas je n'excuse pas cherchons à
comprendre quel est le malaise
aujourd'hui pour qu'on arrive à tant de
violence que ce soit de la partie des
politiques du gouvernement en place ou
même de l'ensemble des citoyens
aujourd'hui
vous savez dans un système capitaliste
on ma toujours expliqué qu'une équipe
est à l'image de son responsable
aujourd'hui notre responsable c'est
emmanuel macron en france il a été élu
pour ça
oui on est peut-être à l'image de notre
président c'est à dire violent alors on
va on va parler dans deux minutes avec
macao qui va nous dire si ce qu'il a
pensé au niveau de la sécurité
olivo livre vous est-ce que vous
condamnez se l'est moi j'ai deux
certitudes en fait si elle sait que je
serai jamais l'apologie de la haine et
de la violence ne serait ce que pour ma
fille c'est bien et pour l'éducation de
ma fille née ça déjà c'est maintenant je
pense que l'acte qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
c'est une réponse à une violence d'état
une violence d'état qui soient fiscales
sociales et aussi dans la rue par les
actes parce que ce gouvernement a fait
parce que le responsable de tout ça
c'est emmanuel macron
et puis et puis votre gouvernement on
entend partout une montée de la colère
est montée de la haine ça fait trois ans
qu'on le répète écouter un petit peu les
français parce que le jour où ça va
péter
là il sera trop tard ça fait 3 sans qu
on vous lit mais vous n'avez rien à
faire mal face et vous continuez sur
votre ligne de conduite et vous
continuez vous continuez ce qu'on est en
train d'assister aujourd'hui c'est des
français qui sont à bout de souffle à
bout de tous ils n'en peuvent plus et ça
et un jour ça finira par yves ollivier
et ça c'est triste et haut niveau dans
ses filets